[Music]
let's go to heather in chicago hey
heather what's going on
hi dr john how are you i'm so good how
about you
i'm good i'm good outstanding how can i
help
um i just was wondering how i can
be fun again without alcohol
oh my goodness what a question dig into
that for me how can i be fun again
without alcohol
yes so
um i am
i'm
i
am trying to learn i've stopped i've not
completely stopped drinking alcohol
but i don't
drink as much as i used to
and what happened that made you stop
i just didn't like um how i was i didn't
i didn't do
too much i don't think but even
i started looking more like i'd have a
glass
of wine while i was making dinner and
then
it turned into two and then it turned
into three
and i wasn't sleeping well and i just
i'm trying to just better myself
and
um
i'd also go out in social situations and
just have way too much okay to drink and
i feel like
it made me fun
and
now i feel like when i go out i'll have
a drink or two when i go out with
friends but i don't feel like i'm fun
anymore
so what makes that make sense oh
absolutely
what made you fun
what did alcohol give you and talking to
the phone just directly this is really
important i want anyone to miss this
what what made you fun
um
i guess just being
more outgoing
and
i don't know just
able to open up more i guess these
people
and
just be more
outgoing i guess i don't know
and so now you go out and you realize
i don't even like these people
or you go out and realize i'd rather be
at home by myself watching netflix or
i'd rather be home yeah
doing other things than this
yeah yeah be with my family yeah
i'd rather be with my family than with
you idiots
how old are you
i am 38. 38. man
so we can go down a rabbit hole on this
one
and i'm so i can do a whole show on this
i could do two shows on this
um
and there's a couple of great books out
on this right now
um that i just i mean literally this
weekend i just
ran across one
okay in a nutshell
oh man she's always weak
this is such a big thread once you start
pulling untangling it
here's the deal you weren't fun
you weren't having fun
right what alcohol allows you to do is
to numb everything out
and it allowed you to be in a situation
that you didn't want to be in doing
things that you didn't want to do
and it allowed you to get past that
voice in your head saying won't just go
home this is stupid
because you pos you didn't like the loud
you didn't like
the hooking up you didn't like the jokes
you didn't like the just talk whatever
we were talking about whatever it is
alcohol you thought was making it more
fun for you
it took that away
and then at home
my guess is you found yourself being
with your family but there's something
about it that is stressful is exhausting
is
high expectations you don't think you're
achieving whatever
and then all of a sudden you find
yourself present with your family
physically but absolutely not present
emotionally and spiritually and
psychologically is that fair
yes so what about being at home
what about being with your friends
isn't enough
what is it about being with your family
being with your friends that you feel
like you've got to
put a pillow over those feelings
um
gosh that's a good question
i'm not sure
what i will tell you is the research is
telling us
here's what we're seeing right so
men for eternity have run everything
right and we know this they have the
most money they've got the most space
whatever they also drink a lot right
this is a global phenomenon all over
earth
and they lead the planet in
strokes heart attacks cancers etc
and what they're calling it is diseases
of despair they've worked and achieved
themselves to death
now i work a lot i love what i do i like
achievement i like competition
what i've had to spend the last decade
doing is divorcing my identity from
those things right those are things that
i do not things that i am right
okay and so
when i step back and look at alcohol has
allowed
power people in power to keep going as
does cocaine as does any number of
distraction addictions anger rage a new
girlfriend a new girlfriend a new wife a
new car new whatever right
it allows you just to keep going and
keep going and keep going because the
signals in our bodies that say are we
enjoying this is this actually where we
want to be you can shut those signals
off
right that's what alcohol does
and what we've seen over the last 25
years
is oh man
we're seeing a
in mass
women
becoming like these glass ceilings are
shattering and women are working hard
and they're there and they're crushing
it and they're doing so good and they're
being told hey by the way you have to be
the ceo and be a present mom and be at
home and do all these things and make
sure this is done and this is done and
this is done
and so the the game got bait and
switched on you and they got bait and
switched on
on male partners too everyone's in the
middle of a big bait and switch and what
we're seeing on an almost vertical trend
line
is
women are starting to catch up with
heart issues and cancer issues their
bodies are starting to to wait to wear
this too
and then you see the alcohol
relationship and it's almost a vertical
trend line and now you can't go to
target without
the shirts that say like you know
my my wine my sippy cup is a wine glass
or whatever you know those little cute
sayings and all that stuff right
it's become super normed
and instead of being heartbroken we're
all cheering about it
and here's what's happening
women
this is not a controversial statement by
and large women are smarter than men and
they um
are more connected more grounded than
men are this is just a generalized
statement you can put mean things in the
in the youtube comments whatever
and i think sooner they are recognizing
whoa this is not what i signed up for
like you mentioned i don't like
myself at home i don't feel good i don't
sleep good
um i'm out when i i'm out at the bar and
these people are idiots i don't have fun
right so the question you have to ask
yourself is
how do you build a life
how do you build a life that you don't
need to numb from
that you don't need to run from
what does that look like can you
articulate that for me
um
what conversations are you not having at
home
that you need to numb out from
what conversations
do you have to have with yourself about
hey these used to be my friends they're
just not anymore we're just different
now yeah like what are those
conversations that you need to have with
you and with your husband with people in
your life
well i know at home i feel
like really overwhelmed and
um
like i'm pretty much just
the only adult doing the things around
the house and taking care of the kids
and all of that so is your husband just
abandoning you on this have you all
talked about it no no
um
and we haven't like i haven't really
just got down and talked to him about it
but
um he's pleasant he's pleasant he just
he's possibly work and so when he comes
home
it's just not
there's not a whole lot of help but
i don't know do you want to
i don't okay i don't
know
so you are trapped in a guilt cycle that
says he's out working so i should be
doing all this stuff
and his job is this and my job is that
and
your job is
weighing on you heavy and you don't feel
like you're good enough at it and so
like a good man you're drinking the end
of the day away because your job's hard
and you don't ask for help
yep congratulations you're pretty much
you pretty much 100 percent hit it on
the head with i don't feel like i'm good
enough yeah you are i
you are
okay but then how do you in a social
situation
everyone else is like drinking i don't
want to it's not i'm i'm good at
stopping but then i feel like i'm just
here's the hardest thing in the world
about stopping drinking i think this is
me
is you've got to change social circles
yeah and when you stop drinking
people around you either a want to keep
going and you ruin that for them that's
what they tell themself
or they feel indicted by your behavior
change
they know they'd like to quit too and
they can't
they know they want to make some life
changes and they can't
and so i think this is just me i mean
data to back this up or anything i think
the hardest thing about making any major
life change like this same with if you
want to change your diet you want to
lose a bunch of weight and start eating
healthier
um those folks that you always went out
with every all the time
you quit going
or you're that guy at the
you know the chinese food place that
brings you lunch you don't want to be
her right so you just don't go
or you show up and you're eating carrots
and then people are going to make fun of
you because
they are indicted about what they're
eating same with alcohol
the hardest part of here is you have to
step back and say are these people still
my friends
and if you cannot have a connected
conversation with somebody without a
drink they are not your friend
okay
and i hate to say that like that
yeah what your husband
deserves
is you being honest about where you are
in your heart in your head because
here's the thing he feels it
in whatever way he's
he's numbing too
and i don't know how that's another
phone call my guess is you know how
yeah or you have your suspicions how but
he's numbing too because he misses you
also
and so what we have is we have
a generation of women trying to do the
world
try to trying to enter trying to
interact i mean say that way the
generation of women trying to interact
with the world
on its own power structure
that's killing everybody
and we have a group of men who are
saying i don't want this anymore but i
don't have any models any pictures i
don't have any way to get from here to
there i don't even know what there is
and that's when
whether it's you y'all have a great
relationship or you need to go talk to a
marriage counselor together to help
somebody have this conversation with you
and by the way me and my wife have this
conversation
on a regular basis
so
perfection doesn't mean you arrive
perfection means you practice this right
it's kind of like a a workout i can't
just work out once and call it i'm in
shape for the rest of my life i got to
keep going right so this whole thing is
constantly evolving and how old are your
kids
12
7 and 10. okay so
your whole world is just a blender right
and yeah when one of them turns 15 and
one of them right this is just going to
keep happening things are going to keep
shifting and then you're going to have
two in middle school and one in high
school and then one going to college one
mil all this is going to keep shifting
shifting shifting which means you're all
going to have you and your husband have
to come up with a
not a solution forever
but a way that we we have we create new
solutions along the way you have to
create new train tracks for your train
to go on
okay but you're gonna have to look in
the mirror and say i'm
good that's hard i know it is i know it
is
the whole world's telling you you're not
enough
that you should be at work you should be
doing this your house should look like
that your boys should never say these
things and they should be all of it
there's an entire world telling you that
you're not enough and for whatever it's
worth there's an entire world telling
him he's not enough either
and so it's two people who committed to
ride or die together forever
looking at each other going you know
what you're good and i'm good
we can do better than this and we can do
it together
what do you need
how can i honor you in this right how do
i turn the offs offs and the ons on
and you telling him i've got to build a
life here that i don't need to numb out
from
and i'm drinking too much
i'm drinking period i don't feel good i
don't like it i don't like who i am
after drink three
i don't like my kids if they asked if i
asked my kids to draw a picture of me it
would have me with a wine glass i don't
like any of that stuff
yeah
and here's the thing you want to get
back to being quote unquote fun
turn music up in your house and dance so
you can't dance make your boys have
dance-offs with you
yeah plan romantic getaways or fun
intimate time with your husband y'all
decide and if it's awkward lean into the
awkward and invite him along with that i
don't know who you used to be
before your world became something that
you had to hide from
that's the adventure that you and your
husband can go on together
what did that look like and you're going
to find things that you have so deeply
buried that you're going to probably
spend some time with a professional
counselor to unbury those things to dig
them up
that's fair that's part of it
but don't oh my gosh
i started tracking my sleep and i've
almost entirely limited alcohol of
everything
even
tiny social search
it messes my sleep up it's a poison it's
just bad for you okay
there's a lot of good books out right
now on this stuff
um we're seeing a gentle turn away from
alcohol at the same time we're seeing
alcohol consumption among women at a
just a
rocket ship pace
and
um all sort of all sort of addiction
numbers are all through the roof after
you know years of cove and all that
stuff
don't build a life you don't have to
hide from i'll just leave it at that i
keep saying this over and over and maybe
we'll do a whole show on alcohol it's a
whole thing man you're better than this
you're better than this you're better
than this
if you are listening to this and you
think whoa whoa whoa i'm down a road
that i don't want to be down
get with somebody immediately somebody
you trust
and begin asking those hard questions
ugh thank you so so much for that call